theo brendan eria nick
reporting live uh from tatami desert in
the northern territory australia
yeah australia boys love your work
love the show keep it up look forward to
it every week
boys got a uh you can look at him more
like debatable
club for you this is razzle dangerously
hugh jackman or russell crowe
oh
this girl got sick bro russell crowe
same dive as us he's got beautiful eyes
russell crowe and he was in cinderella
man
oh you're right good [ __ ] pole there
dude first of all i didn't even realize
till just now that he wasn't cinderella
man
second of all he came to the comedy
store a couple times and saw me do
comment i actually have his number in my
phone
oh text him see if i'll facetime in and
ask if we're doing
gladiator too see what he says look at
that body and that's if he's doing
gladiator i already bugged him about
some stuff he needed to respond so
i'm gonna back off but um
but dude he was the nicest guy he came
out to the comedy store a couple times
um dude hugh jackman's so talented the
wolverine
yeah can't name another movie though
uh what was the magic one prestige
oh hard pass it was great christmas
magician
hard pass
swordfish that boy's bodied up though he
got on that rock diet
it was funny he became wolverine and was
on the front cover of men's health and
like oh how'd you get so jacked he's
like well the rock called me
basically means the rocks on bunch
steroids
see hugh jackman did uh les miserables
yeah the hard path
he also did that singing one
uh les miserables no oh uh the great the
greatest
showman oh yeah and it's zac efron's in
it you don't realize that
uh hugh jackman can sing you you texting
uh homeboy
ask him for me if he's doing uh part two
gladiator it's been
a decade or more
i don't think they're going to get to it
brendan well
you have his number only one way to find
out i will ask him what other movie has
he done
i can't find his number um so i uh i
might even have i might not even have
his number
i might have literally been bothering
someone who isn't russell crowe
he might have gave you a fake number but
he's a great american gangster
dude he's done so many great projects
and now he produces a lot of his
different movies
don't say projects you're right don't
say projects like you're in the business
yeah you're right dude
he's done he's done a lot of great films
that i've watched
yeah beautiful mind great film oh god
when you think
bro he's underrated isn't he in a weird
way yeah he's a [ __ ]
like he's like he's definitely like but
he doesn't get thrown in that category a
lot of times
sin bro cinderella man alone was amazing
damn he's done a lot of films yeah
oh we did the one on the water too
remember where they're looking for
something
which one man commander male man master
and commander
mastering commander pirates i didn't see
it
but i will russell oh dude van helsing
dude the vampire killer bro it's really
a great this is a great comparison man
that's really really tough
bro and god bless but this australia
versus scotland man it's two freaking
underdog
continents oh is he from scotland yes
brother
are you looking up nick i don't is he no
no you're thinking of uh
dude who did 300 nah he's from scotland
who's that gerard butler rod butler oh
i'm princess gerard butler
i was literally gonna say are you
talking about gerard butler
[Laughter]
sorry i've never met russell crowe
to gerard butler i'm thinking of russell
brand i
have a buddy who's real friends with
gerard butler and uh they're at dinner
and you know he loves women and he was
saying 300 came out and this is like
currently you know he's out of shape you
just get older he gets
he's not you don't have that 300 body
anymore and he says he'll get in a room
with a lady
and they'll be like damn man what
happened like [ __ ] that was 10 years
ago
yeah i just don't stay in 300 mode [ __ ]
he's like too late
gerard butler that's my friend right
there yeah that ain't your friend
the pride of scotland dude
he's a good actor bro he's a good actor
he was in
cinderella man
[Laughter]
dude here's a crazy i bet he could just
tell people he was in cinderella
and that's a great part
um first of all this looks like razzle
dangerously the comedian
in disguise which i could tell second of
all i would love to have a wife from
australia so if there's any australian
women who will want to be a white
oh you want a down under 90 day fiance
dude yeah
hell yeah yeah britain you think i'm
marrying one of these american women
with all their freaking [ __ ]
okay i can see that you're on it today
doug and he even got stashed up at one
point oh wow that actually that's a good
pull right there